starting with your values identifying  which values you cherish most and  there's no right or wrong answers here  like maybe it's your  marriage maybe it's parenting career  finances you know it's just getting  clear on  on the priority list of these things and  then figuring out like  how are these values being most  nourished daily and then getting  granular to ask yourself if a 60k race  fits into that value set or value  structure or whether it comes at the  peril  of these other values does it  exceedingly threaten  your marriage or your relationship and  then asking well if it does  is it worth it or is there a way to  pursue this goal nourish these values  and keep both of them intact it's about  asking yourself whether the goal  fulfills the value